[Music]
what keeps bill nye up at night when
thinking about this scenario
climate change and asteroid impacts
asteroid impact you know as we say
very low probability very high
consequence
to put it in in pc
personal computer terms i think it's
control
alt delete for all of civilization
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so peter richard have you ever thought
about evacuating the earth of course not
i have never thought about evacuating
the earth i haven't got a spaceship
there's nowhere i would go
if you're talking about the earth
meaning land going underwater no i
haven't thought of that either or
going into space none of it in fact none
of it i've not thought about it at all
sorry stop grilling me
yes i know all of a sudden it's
interrogations so
uh the scenario is uh us president
morgan freeman wouldn't that be nice
deep impact reference which i'm
sure you don't remember or never saw is
it a movie it is a movie never saw it
so in that scenario of course there was
literally one of these situations
where an asteroid was barreling down to
earth i can't remember if they had 30
days or
three months or whatever it was but he
had to sort of
break the news to the world that now we
had to quote unquote evacuate the earth
with that little time it was a bit of a
noah's ark scenario where
obviously everybody wasn't getting on
you know good ship goodbye
there's probably not enough space to
take more than
i don't know a few thousand i think in
this scenario was do you first of all do
you believe you and i
are are maybe on that ship perhaps as
podcasters
well i mean they've got to have wherever
they're going they'll need
podcasts my guess is they take joe rogan
and marc maron and not
peter and richard so you you don't think
we're necessarily on the mount rushmore
currently of podcast nowhere near and
i'm happy to say that so we
obviously would want to have a better
skills uh more
indispensable skills if we are going to
be on
that sort of versus you know we better
start working now if we want to get some
final countdown final question please i
know that song
europe yes um but somebody who would
probably be on
that ship because they're going to need
scientists okay
and they're going to need communicators
who are very good at explaining science
and you know
of course that means bill nye
yes the science guy no it's another bill
nye entirely
we couldn't get bill nye the science guy
but we got a guy he's just he's got some
theories
yeah he's got some ideas he's got some
strong opinions bill nye is a zebra
breeder
yes he's a zebra breeder no of course
actually i'm being facetious we do have
bill nye the science guy joining us
today to discuss
what if we had to evacuate the earth
bill nye is a scientist engineer
comedian
author and inventor he's also a man with
a mission
to help foster a scientifically literate
society and to help people everywhere
understand and appreciate the science
that makes our world work
bill's classic show bill nye the science
guy was nominated for 23 emmys and
won 19 and it paved the way for a career
in making science accessible fun and
super cool
and he's still doing exactly that with
his sensationally
entertaining and informative podcast
science rules
with bill nye
bill thanks so much for joining us i
think it's fair to say for everybody
here at what if
and our incredible fans in the community
that we sort of stand on your shoulders
here what if probably doesn't exist in
terms of being out there
as something that looks to make science
accessible and fun
building on the legacy of what you've
been doing for decades now so
just really thrilled to have you here
thanks for joining us
well thank you you guys i mean uh wow
sure you're welcome the mount rushmore
hopefully in in years to come will be
bill nye maybe peter maybe
we'll see how it goes today but i mean
as far as scenarios and
obviously today's what if is you know
kind of a a scary one
it's not one we want to think about
having to evacuate the earth before we
sort of get into it
uh we know that we're monitoring stuff
in space all the time we've never been
better at it but we also know there's
surprises
and unanticipated things because it's
space
what keeps bill nye up at night when
thinking about this scenario
uh climate change interesting really
yeah climate change and asteroid impacts
as the two possibilities asteroid impact
you know as we say
very low probability very high
consequence
uh to put it in um in
pc personal computer terms
i think it's control alt delete
for all of civilization so you wouldn't
want that that would be
that's that's what we call bad outcome
in the insurance business
uh so you want to we want to avoid that
and that's why
you know with the comment that just came
through here it was identified in march
with the neo-y
spacecraft neowise is the near-earth
object
uh wide field infrared survey explorer
yes so it was looking for asteroids
and uh you know asteroids as we say it's
like looking for a
charcoal briquette in the dark yeah but
it's uh uh but in the infrared they do
glow and so they're around 200 kelvin
if you could find them uh then maybe you
could identify
whether or not you can determine whether
or not they're going to cross earth's
orbit when we're there
and then you could do something
extraordinary and cool to give them a
nudge
big rocket a big big bomb a big
set of spacecraft that have lasers on
them that
z the asteroid surface and cause it to
ablate
and get a little momentum and nudge
everything out of the way yes
be fantastic except in space there's no
sound so it wouldn't be z
it would just yes it wouldn't sound like
that exactly
a lot of this uh bill is is comes down
to time say we can't redirect it and
it's headed straight for the earth
a lot of it is time for us like how much
time do we have to prepare to get off
the earth
um if if we do get a decent you say get
off the earth what are you we're going
to go to the international space station
or we're going to go to some space
station that is yet to be built
so somebody would have to be building it
right now is that is that what's going
to have to happen we would have had to
have already
started building this well kids people
colleagues my esteemed i appreciate that
deflecting an asteroid everybody wants
20 years but let's call it 30 years
notice
30 years notice that's a lot but it's
not that much
you know if you're in high school right
now by the time you're a captain of
industry you'll be
driving the ship and giving the asteroid
a nudge
but this these extraordinary and amazing
ideas
of building enormous space stations
on the scale of uh geosynchronous orbits
you know things 36 000 kilometers above
the earth's surface
or uh 34 000 above the surface whatever
these are
just lovely fun physics problems
you know can i say v squared over r or
whatever the
velocity squared divided by the radius
nothing but fun
who's going to pay for this thing who's
going to build this giant thing
and it would at some point you know
block
some of the earth's some of the sunlight
that hits the earth
and so and i don't mean to be dismissive
they're wonderful cool physics problems
but economically they're very unlikely
don't you think well i mean to your
point earlier about climate change too
if we can't sort of come
together on that that the the sort of
the mobilization required to do that
something like this just seems
almost silly to even consider i guess
well yeah i mean
yes but it is so they're
just cool problems now the reason this
whole thing happened can i try something
you know we had a little technical issue
earlier today everybody
but let's go up here let's all go up
here
onto the old thing and then look over
there can you see
right there that's a poster
of um buzz aldrin walking on the moon
right there okay and what we love about
that if you get up close to it
it says aldrin's visor reflects
armstrong
that's all it says the caption aldrin's
visor reflects
armstrong it doesn't say and they were
on the moon
and the reason they were on the moon is
the u.s committed about the cost of
three interstate highway systems
to put them there so
if you're just evaluating things which
is more valuable the interstate highway
system or
six people walking on the moon or 12
people walking on the moon six missions
uh you'd probably say the interstate
highway system probably
and the reason that happened that
happened
was because of the cold war because the
former soviet union
was perceived as this terrible threat
and through
a remarkable political circumstance
a president declared we're going to go
to the moon and then he was
catastrophically
killed and so then his legacy just took
on this life of its own
and uh we went people went to the moon
walked around
brought back some moon rocks which have
been great and continue to be a great
scientific value
but if you just wanted moon rocks to
determine the age of the earth
which has been the big the wonderful
scientific outcome of that
of the moon rocks you would you could do
it much more cheaply you know
robotically in fact the former soviet
union sent
a rover there and brought back a few
kilos robotically
but it doesn't have the same romance and
so when you when we talk about these
stanford tauruses tauri tuarai
torai see here's the thing you know
along with my many other uh
difficulties i took three years of latin
oh wow
so you get i'm look i'm fine uh you get
into this thing of how
how do you pronounce it as an alumni
alumni alumnae
tori torai monkeys
monkai
it's so stressful to even think about it
no more are you
are you are you do you see like people
have talked about living on the moon
settlements on the moon
going to mars living on mars is that
also
within the realm of not worth
considering right now to your
like or do you see that as more likely
here's the thing if i were king of the
foothist
i would want to go to mars but i want to
come back
you know mars is smaller than the earth
it cooled off faster than the earth it
got an ocean and an
atmosphere perhaps a billion years
before the earth did
so it is reasonable that if life is
going to start
someplace where there's water it started
on mars
and it is extraordinary but not crazy
or or irrational to suggest
that life started on mars mars was hit
with an impactor
and then exception space as i like to
joke it's just
a rock came to earth and you and i are
descendants of some martian life form
that is extraordinary and that is a
hypothesis it's worth investigating
especially
at the very low cost of interplanetary
missions compared to all the other crazy
things we do
yeah and i mean everything's on the
table now these days but to your point
yeah
anyway the perseverance rover is on its
way there with
some astrobiology experiments on board
to investigate this hypothesis i mean
it's really
it's just a wild old time it's wow
we're going to say goodbye to our the
video viewers on our podcast and we're
going to catch up with you on the other
side on the audio podcast but before we
go
uh our viewers are obviously big fans of
yours where can they go to
follow you or what kind of cool things
have you got coming up
well everybody your home page i'm sure
is billny.com but while you're there go
to the podcast
homepage askbill9.com
and send us your question the podcast is
called science rules
we do two versions is it okay to pitch a
podcast
on a podcast yes and in fact it actually
makes you conversations the regular
about hour long version and then
the much shorter coronavirus edition
which we do every two weeks
we've had tony fauci on we've had bruce
brilliant we've had celine counter
people that you see on
the tv we've had them on the show
uh we had arne duncan who in the u.s was
very known
a guy about well-known guys head of the
department of education
talking about opening schools during
coronavirus
uh at pandemic and so these people are
very thoughtful and they
i encourage you to check us out science
rules at stitcher mid roll
wow so bill nye a guy who knows a lot
also a guy
who probably never stops learning
doesn't sound like it doesn't
no and i think you're a guy who likes to
never stop learning am i right
not to the same level of of absorption
let's say as a guy like bill nye the
science client yes i love to learn i
love to continue to learn just like we
do every week on this show
well now is the time to continue your
studies or your
learning because you know with covid19
we're all at home we've got
most of us have a little bit of extra
time to learn well why don't you become
more informed
creative inspired relaxed all with the
great courses plus
we're really big fans of this aren't we
well so i was at home the other day and
this sounds made up but it isn't i'm
going
i'm setting up my smart tv because i
just moved so i'm going through the apps
available on my smart tv
there's our old friend
greatcoursesplus.com i'm thinking maybe
i could jump in and get prepared for the
bill nye episode
moon rocks there's a whole episode on
moon rocks from the apollo mission
uh this uh professor bob hazen is
talking about this
is in his words the scientific bonanza
that that created
50 years ago when they just came home
with a few rocks for the moon you'd
think well that's kind of what is it a
paperweight no they've been actually
gleaning
tons of scientific info and then all of
a sudden we're talking to bill
nye earlier and he's talking about moon
rocks and how
they've actually helped us understand
what the age of
our planet continents here uh you know
minerals and elements in the earth like
it's incredible the amount of knowledge
we've been able to glean from moon rocks
and incredible the amount of knowledge
i was able to glean from a great courses
episode that i was getting ready for
this show well let me tell you the great
courses plus
has not only that but thousands of
lectures on almost any topic imaginable
from the history of egypt to the study
of dna and
new courses are added all the time
there's someone for everyone not just
moon rock lovers like yourself plus
every course
is presented like you say by subject
matter experts from top
universities and institutions it's
in-depth reliable
fact-based information and you can watch
or listen
from your phone or your tv with the
great courses plus app at
any time from anywhere in the world so
make the most of your time
keep learning with the great courses
plus right now they're offering fans of
this show an amazing deal
an entire month of access for free
this limited time offer won't last so
sign up today to get started
go to thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if don't wait go to the great
courses thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if i think you meant to say
thegreatcoursesplus.com
that's i think exactly what i said so
let's go there and get your free month
so quick summary from bill nye the
summary was basically
he's not obvious it's not happening it's
too it's too expensive
yeah mars is unlikely um certainly even
mobilizing people around doing something
like this
and in the end really his i don't know
his overall message is kind of what like
keep an eye on the planet and keep care
of what you have right now
i mean which is what we should have all
been thinking in the first place i don't
know why
we really think that oh yeah we're just
going to leave the earth and we're going
to go find some
goldilocks planet to live on yeah it's
not easy as he says
it's going to take all the resources of
all the governments in the world or all
the money
and we're not going to get 7.7 billion
people off the planet so
how about we just stop polluting and
stop chopping down all the trees and
yeah if we thought that was a reasonable
plan b after talking to bill nye
not so much yeah yeah and as you asked
him as well
in the end this is all about time what
scenario would we ever have
where we really had enough of a lead up
to get anybody really off this planet in
any real way
30 years yeah and 30 years i mean come
on we
we can't even get it together to build a
new bridge in three years
or whatever it is and certainly focus on
things like climate change
so again not that he was being
pessimistic but he was he was being
really realistic
in that look guys that's not really an
option so
you better just focus on what you have
here at home and devote whatever energy
time and
and even hypotheticals to how can we
solve this problem here before we start
thinking about
maybe evacuating the earth that's right
wall
uh if you enjoyed this discussion with
bill nye and you want to check out some
more with richard and i and bill nye
well
why don't you click on the link in the
description below
which is a link to our extended audio
version where bill will continue on
chatting with us this time he's going to
touch on
how many people we could possibly get
off this planet
well when you say getting off the earth
how many people are you talking about
you know that
10 000 you know uh there are 7.6 7.7
billion people
and um uh getting 10 000 off the earth
is good
but i don't think it's what uh
it's not a a solution that everybody's
crazy about
you know yeah and more than just how
many people can get off the planet he
actually we went on for
i don't know a long time going in all
sorts of cool super wild directions
about basically the cosmos life on other
planets i mean this is not something to
be honest you want to miss
no you never want to miss anything that
bill nye says because it's informative
and it's funny well or if it was just
you and i you wouldn't want to miss it
either but yes
bill brings an extra layer of he's
professionalism credibility authority
and entertainment though he's the third
dimension to our chat but he's really
the fourth dimension that's how i like
to think of it
all right join us next time on what if
discussed
you